MMM,
no,
we've all had daydreams about being able
to fly.
We can't defy the laws of physics,
but we can still dream about it.
So what does it mean when a character in
a film gets to fly?
Let's look at a classic example in the
adults of the community showing
conformity,
hostility to anything new,
xenophobia,
suspicion and a lack of imagination or
bearing down on our young heroes.
They've even set up a roadblock at just
the moment when things look worse to the
bicycles.
Leave the earth and with it,
the earthbound grownups we see escape,
wonder magic and freedom through flight.
Flying is freedom.
Let's do some closer readings of flying
and film.
Jenny and forrest gump wants to be free.
She wants to fly away from her troubles.
She has a sexually abusive alcoholic
father.
She praised a flyaway,
but does she get her wings?
Kind of.
The police do take her to her
grandmother,
so she's technically free from her
father,
but this camera shot tells a different
story.
The camera moves up into the sky and
birds fly away with us,
but Jenny stays put on the ground in a
literal sense.
She does get freed from her father,
but figuratively,
she's still stuck.
She can't fly away from the emotional
damage her father cost.
Look at the shot of her as an adult
still falling to the ground at the sight
of her old house.
The camera shot is placed firmly at
ground level reflecting that she still
grounded.
She failed to free herself from the
shackles of her past.
Throughout the movie,
we see her trying to fly away and fail
each time.
I think I a flap.
This bridge,
the closeup on her shoes,
shows Jenny trying to leap out of them,
but she can't.
She stuck later.
She tries to using drugs to forget her
abuse and fly away.
The song freebird playing in the
background during this scene is
definitely no coincidence.
Now when she wants to fly,
she's higher up in a building and
wearing high heels,
but no matter how much she tries
extending herself upwards,
she's still slips and facing the reality
that she can't fly.
She can't escape the scars of her
childhood,
only when Jenny goes back home to forest
that she start to emotionally recover.
Nobody can fly away from their past,
but we can confront it,
accept and move on.
She dies,
but she doesn't die alone are trapped.
She dies in the company of people she
loves and that's when she truly becomes
free like a bird.
Sometimes in film,
the character does feel like they're
flying.
We can see parallels between Jenny's
attempted fight and roses,
flight and titanic in the beginning.
Suicide off the back of the titanic
seems to be the only chance of escape.
Rose has from her rich plain lifestyle
and unwanted marriage with Jack.
However,
she can now embrace a new found beauty
in her life at the front of the boat.
Look at the difference between these
static dark closeups on the back of the
ship and the sweeping shots of color in
the later seen.
We perceive some innate beauty to the
idea of flying that's reflected in
titanic.
Birdman has such an interesting
portrayal of flight because in the film
are hero Reagan Thompson rejects flight.
He chooses to stay on the ground and
perform his play in Birdman.
Flight is still a symbol of freedom,
but it's a freedom.
Reagan wants to avoid.
Reagan wants to stay grounded and face
reality.
His place seeks to comment on the issues
of being human.
With flight.
A person escapes the struggles of being
human,
so flight means we no longer need the
philosophical discussions being human
because we've escaped the need for them,
rick and wants to stay on the ground
because he wants to make art.
That actually means something.
If he flies and makes superficial
superhero movies,
he'll be unable to make any profound
commentary on the human condition
because through flight he has escaped
the human condition.
He stays on the ground so he can comment
on the struggles of being grounded in
his play.
So what about the flight at the end of
the film?
I think this is a different kind of
flight,
mainly because it's not just him that
sees it.
His daughter does.
By this time in the film,
Reagan has overcome the need to please
others.
He does is play and does what he wants
purely for himself.
He transcended our needs as humans to
fit in and please others,
and we see this transcendence
represented through flight.
He achieved a higher sense of being both
literally and symbolically,
so maybe we can't defy the laws of
physics and fly,
but if you manage to figure out yourself
and your place in the universe,
it's sure
this is.
This is falling with style.
Thanks for watching.